the federal agency that oversees many of
the nation's nursing homes is urging
governor's to use extreme caution in
easing coronavirus restrictions about a
third of the country's more than 91,000
coronavirus deaths are connected to
nursing homes Jonathan Vigliotti talked
to Seema Verma administrator of the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services can you give us a sense of
timing when families can expect to see
their loved ones is it a matter of weeks
a matter of months well we hope it's as
quickly as possible because we recognize
how important it is for patients and
their families Seema Verma the
administrator for the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services says the
decision to allow visitors to return to
nursing homes should depend on
coronavirus cases in the community
inspections of especially hard-hit
facilities and testing for staff and
residents we've already seen governor's
across the nation taking action around
testing in their nursing homes and we
think that's a very important component
towards reopening nursing homes patient
advocates say the lack of testing and
personal protective equipment is partly
to blame for the high death toll and
warned these facilities need better
access to both before they can reopen
CMS has restricted visitors since March
to protect residents the agency's
guidelines allow families in to say
goodbye but some we've spoken with say
they were denied can you please tell us
right now and nursing homes more
importantly what these guidelines are
you know from the very beginning our
guidelines have been clear and so in the
case of end-of-life nursing homes should
allow family members to come in are you
thinking of making that mandatory so
there is no room for error here no
misinterpretation we want to do
everything we can to make sure that
nursing home residents have the best
quality of life at least 28,000 people
connected to long-term care facilities
have died I'm curious to know how you
would grade yourself in the response to
this pandemic so far I think it's also
important to understand that the
oversight of nursing homes is a joint
federal and state effort how would you
grade that effort that joint effort what
kind of grade would you place on that
you know I think that we've taken strong
action from the very beginning and we've
continued to put out regulations we meet
daily with CDC we've been going and
doing inspections some of the hardest
hit homes had a history of citations for
lapses and infection prevention and
control and staff shortages did your
agency do enough in regulating nursing
homes to make sure that they were
protected for a pandemic of this kind so
going into the pandemic if you look at
some of the work that we did last year
is we actually revamped the entire
system and created new tools we've
actually increased the number of fines
for nursing homes and we identified some
1,200 nursing homes across the country
that we knew were struggling with
infection control and CMS says a
commission of industry experts will meet
later this month to look back at the
response and identify best practices but
critics argue that panel should have met
much earlier in this crisis firma says
the commission is just one of the
agency's efforts to help facilities
Anthony all right Jonathan thank you
hard to believe the government can be
satisfied with the way this is the
pandemic has played out in nursing homes
given as you point out the death toll
thanks